all right today we going to start
lecturing on things related to the third
chapter of the book that you've been
assigned and I have also asked you to to
read a number of rather brief text
dealing with cosmogony or the the coming
into being of the cosmos these are
listed on course works I believe for
under the third session one of the
readings is from the book of Genesis
another from the cosmogony or the
Theogony of Hesiod who was a
contemporary of Homer another from the
younger Edda which is one of the two
classic works of Norse mythology one
from through the Rig Veda verse you know
book 10 verse 90 the so called purusha
sukta and one of them is a text from a
russian poem reflect to the 19th century
that in some ways combines both the
Vedic and the and the biblical
perspectives I thought of going farther
into cosmogony in general but it
there's a question as to how important
cosmogony is do you need to know how the
universe came into being he said for
example is less interested in cosmogony
the origin of the universe than he is in
the origin of the gods and these are two
separate topics although presumably they
come in some sort of succession
you know the gods do not precede the
universe in most cosmic journeys
although you could argue that in the
biblical cosmology no one God does
precede the universe because the
universe is created by that God
other versions have some concept of a
void or chaos or some sort of state of
cosmological non-being from which the
universe emerges
in and I'm not going to try and
anticipate for you what's in these
readings because I'd like you to think
about them and discuss them in
discussion sections I would point out
that if you if you try and trace this
into into China you get a an interesting
figure named Pangu and in Chinese
cosmogony there was originally a chaos
and the chaos coalesced into an egg and
when the egg hatched out came Pangu and
the chaos was perfectly balanced between
yin and yang and so you get a immediate
conjunction of the notion of a cosmogony
but also the notion of a dualistic
balance of entities and then after
eighteen thousand years Han GU dies and
the world that we know it the material
world that we know is made out of taking
different parts of his body you know
initially he is sort of like atlas he
separates the heaven from the earth you
know he pushes up and put with his arms
and down with his feet and gradually he
becomes taller and taller and the
heavens and the earth become farther and
farther apart but the the creation of
actual things comes from from his body
and as you'll see any other readings
this notion of a primal being whose body
gives rise to different material things
including living beings I believe it's
obviously the lice or the you know ticks
on pongos body a give rise to animals
something like that low priority uh if
you if you look at cross cultures you
find that this notion of the the
division of this primal being is fairly
widespread but in a sense the
interesting part about the Chinese
example is that it appears rather late
and various scholars have have guessed
that maybe it's simply borrowed and then
it's not really a Chinese cosmology me
so much as a story that some Chinese
writers got from somewhere else and when
they speculate on that they say well
where would this story have come from
and then zap they're back in the Middle
East they're back to Egypt to
Mesopotamia and ancient Greece and so
forth and it becomes a scholarly way of
saying well you know maybe really the
ancient Middle East is the center of
everything no when you go to the ancient
Middle East why does it appear why do we
get a whole chapter on it particularly
and the clue is that when you count the
pages have the words in the chapter you
find that the great plurality of the
words are those that are devoted to the
story of Israel and the the fact the
matter is that the Bible
is a huge influence on thinking about
world history there's a question whether
one can ever escape the Bible though not
nothing you should want to escape the
Bible I'm not advocate advocating some
sort of you know mass rejection of
biblical religious tradition interesting
that they can history escape the Bible
in other words to talk of a theme that I
mentioned before if you were seeking to
write the history of the world for all
the world's peoples would you have a
chapter heavily devoted to the stories
contained in the Bible and to the
countries that the people in the Bible
were either from or came into contact
with there are two ways in which history
is is affected by the Bible one of them
is fairly recent its basic it basically
becomes concretize in the 19th century
though it has roots that go back
somewhat earlier and that is to try to
test whether the stories that are found
in the Bible can be demonstrated as true
through archaeology or other work that
is done on the ground
this effort arose largely as I say in
the 19th century and it was part of a
much broader movement to try to test the
truth of Jewish and Christian faith
assumptions against against rationality
it's part of the great struggle between
faith and reason as it played out in the
19th century during the period when when
enlightenment rationality and Industrial
Revolution scientism were becoming we're
coming together through course in many
respects Darwin's notions becoming the
most the most controversial test the
idea of of trying to check out the
reality of the biblical stories does not
begin at that time but it takes a new
and more scientific turn for example the
idea that eating of pigs is prohibited
because of the possibility of
contracting trichinosis from parasites
contained in poorly cooked pork is a
19th century view and it's part of a
whole range of views trying to assert
matters of rationality into the
understanding of of Jewish law this is
not what is not new in the sense that
there had always been a question as to
why this belief or that belief is
written into law there is one Talmudic
story of
you know student going to a certain
rabbi and saying no do we not eat this
or do that because of this or because of
that because rabbi a says it's because
of this rabbi B says because of that and
the hero of the story rabbi C says we
don't do it because God tells us not to
do it and you know I'm not going to go
any further than that
it's it's a law yep live with it
you know man up on that but in the 19th
century there was this this this desire
to find rationality in order to to
legitimize a continuing commitment to
faith among a population that was
increasingly being challenged by what
they saw as the progress of the modern
scientific world a lot of archaeology
was done under this inspiration the
archaeology was interpreted variously
depending on who was doing it and what
they found there was an interesting book
published about 20 years ago by a
Lebanese Christian author named Kemal
Celebi entitled the Bible came from
Arabia it was published in a variety of
European languages was quite well
reviewed or at least extensively
reviewed in European press and it never
appeared in the United States he could
not find any publisher that was willing
to publish this book
the thesis of the book was that prior to
the time of of the Kingdom of Israel in
other words if you go back to the era of
the biblical Patriarchs and be wandering
in the desert after the Exodus and so
forth and so on
none of the place names that are
mentioned has ever been located even
though sometimes we'll give a sequence
it'll say we went from here to here to
here to here says nobody's ever found
any of these places he said but if you
go to a very detailed map of Arabia in
the area south of Mecca this is the
province of a seer you'll find all the
place names in precisely the sequences
stated in the Old Testament and the
reason is he concludes as a historian he
says the reason this is the case is
because the history of the ancient
Israelites didn't take place
in the Holy Land it took place in Arabia
hence his title the Bible comes from
Arabia so he says you know it never in
the Old Testament says of the Jordan is
a river it just says it's Jordan says
well there's a there's a cliff there's
an escarpment down there in SCO province
called or done to the Arabic word for
Jordan and if you look over it you look
down onto the fertile plain which is the
land of milk and honey if you look over
the Jordan it's just as bleak on the
other side you sort it on the side
you're looking from now that isn't quite
true if you if you go to the place where
you're supposed to read get a real view
outside of a man you know you do see
fertile fields in the distance but but
commercially he was basically writing a
whole book tongue-in-cheek
to say you know why do we follow this
story which nobody can verify
the question then of Archaeology is one
of the approaches to history that that
is rooted for this part of the world the
middle of the Holy Land
and the surrounding areas in biblical
stories the other approach to history
has to do with the literal story of what
the Bible says taken on principle as a
matter of faith that you know this is
what God said writing in an archaic form
of English under the supervision of King
James the first and and therefore this
is what is true so there you get
something like this this is based on an
archbishop an Anglican Archbishop named
uh sure and it is his conception of how
the world proceeds so you start over
here with Adam and Eve and Cain and Abel
and you run along and the principle of
this chart is to have equal space to
equal to equal time periods so you're
moving along here's Adam and Eve and
here's the Tower of Babel then finally
you get up to King Solomon and the
building of the temple
and here we get Jesus on the cross their
numbers here that tell you how many
centuries have passed since the the
origin of of humankind and so 40
centuries have passed when you get to
Jesus and then of course you work on
past that and you get
I'm sure would these aren't centuries
these are millennia I believe anyway
this kind of thing was taught as normal
history through you know through most of
modern European and American history
instruction even though professional
historians have long has long gotten rid
of it but it's it's not so much that
anybody follow continues to follow this
the succession of specific events yeah
oh yeah
i mean--you is there have been very
careful bogus calculations of exactly
how old the world is and since God
created Adam and Eve on the sixth day
then you know this has to be very very
close to the beginning you know there
are only five days of course those five
days might be billions of years because
nobody knows what a day means but but
that's that's where you get the the
number is two counting backwards adding
up the ages of the patriarchs and so
forth and so on the themes that arise
that one has to to see showing up in
history and to this day in in all sorts
of history are themes like the point
source of humans though there's a
fascination with where did humans
originated now we talk about the Out of
Africa theory there was a prominent
anthropologist named Carleton Kuhn who
back in the 1970s wrote a book
hypothesizing that Homo sapiens comes
into being in four different areas and
that different parts people's into parts
of the world are descended from four
different evolutionary moments and it
massively ridiculed you know the
assumption that everybody has to come
from one place became absolutely
essential because it is what underlies
the notion of universal human equality
which is a a marvelous and
you know ethically uplifting notion it's
just we have no idea whether it's really
true or not but let's assume that it is
true in that it out of Africa's you have
the notion that that it that you have a
point of origin and some people say well
you know where did Eve live you know
where was the primal Eve is it somewhere
in Somalia which these day seems like an
extremely poor choice but at one time
was up
well accompanying this you have the
notion of the Garden of Eden and the
question of was there a peculiarly
salubrious place that gave rise to
humans probably F though archeologists
or would be more inclined to think that
the developments that give rise to
civilization come more from the
challenges of difficult environments
than from the you know the lovely
low-hanging fruit life of Eden but still
the notion of where was Eden remains the
question of that we have today with us
of vegetarianism Adam and Eve are
vegetarians it's very specific in
Genesis
if you are a vegan or a vegetarian which
is sort of veganism light this is a very
important datum because it shows that
eating animals is abnormal and that if
you go back to eating plants it is one
of the ways to go back to the ideal
nature of of one's humanity
I recall one person who reviewed my book
on animals and said I really learned a
lot from this book I wish I'd read years
ago but then I ran into something that
proved that he doesn't know what he's
talking about
and he said because he says as a matter
just a straightforward statement of fact
that Jesus and the 12 disciples were
vegetarians and whereas it is
self-evident that they were vegetarians
and therefore he doesn't know anything
doesn't know what he's talking about and
I found myself wondering what were they
doing fishing where they sport sport
fishermen you know let's drag a Marlin
out of the Sea of Galilee and throw it
back in again so we can catch it again
and then what about those loaves and
fishes because that yeah but it would
fish our red meat maybe that you know
you don't have the loaves and beef
steaks but but you know the the idea
that you would root a contemporary
ideology in a historical myth that goes
back to literally to the dawn times of
humanity and these dawn times not not
being calculated in terms of life on the
savanna or life in the for something
like that but rather the evidence of
Adam and Eve in the garden you know it's
still there
when the Frankenstein monster for the
end is saying that he will go off and
live far from humans and not endanger
anyone and eat only plants you have this
weird recrudescence of the idea of the
vegetarian Edom the separation of
languages with the initially the notion
of the Tower of Babel and yet that
doesn't become the primary part of the
Bible that explains the division of
languages because that occurs before the
flood after the flood what you have are
three sons of Noah Shem ham and Japheth
in the 18th century there was a very
concerted effort in the pioneering days
of historical linguistics to identify
all the world's languages as belonging
to a length to a linguistic descent line
from either Shem or ham or Japheth
because the Bible taught that all the
humans peoples are the descendants of
those three so you had the creation at
that time the 18th century of the notion
of Semitic languages languages that were
spoken by people descended from Shem and
ham edek languages spoken by people
descended from ham when the biblical
story because had the descendants of ham
are assigned the role of being the
servants of their brothers Hamitic
languages were assigned to people in
africa because they become a dis
analysis the natural service of the
white people who speak either Semitic or
genetic languages the language family
that is identified as Semitic is still
called that in other words we have today
a clear-cut set of languages that we've
referred to as Semitic languages even
though I don't think anyone he still
believes that they are because the
speakers are directly sended descended
from Shem but the Semitic languages are
Hebrew Arabic and the languages of
Ethiopia today but you go back
historically and you get Akkadian and
Moabite and other earlier languages and
then you had a group of Hamitic
languages there is no agreement as to
what those languages were but they seem
to be languages of
of Africa but not including the Bantu
group because I don't know nobody seemed
to think put them in nowadays what we're
once called the hammock languages have
been folded into the family of the
Semitic languages and and and it's been
expanded so now you have a group that is
more generally for two as the
afro-asiatic group because it's in
northern parts of africa and in in the
Middle East and the word Hamitic has
disappeared but Semitic remains Jeff
Fenech was a much bigger problem because
nobody could ever people said well we
can identify the Semitic languages we
can vend apply the ham attack languages
then the Jeff Fenech language is a
residual category of everything else but
everything else didn't appear to have
much cohesion so sometimes they get
restricted to the languages of the
Caucasus Mountains between the Black Sea
and the Caspian Sea and then that gets
you know if Jeff etic languages are
spoken in the Caucasus then the people
who speak those languages must be
Caucasians and so the people who are not
Semites you know Arabs and Jews and the
people who are not ham i'ts black
Africans who are serving Arabs and Jews
are the rest of the people who are the
white people the world and they must be
Caucasians because that's where the
genetic languages were spoken and as for
the Western Hemisphere or East Asia or
Southeast Asia who cares now there's a
whole series of these of these tropes of
these themes that have been clearly
outgrown nobody who's likely to get into
Colombia is likely to believe in the
literal truth of these various tropes
and yet they are still very pervasive
and less because of their little meaning
that because of the of the sort of
metaphorical uses to which they can be
put and the story of that's in the Bible
still largely because of this still gets
told and a greater length than either
the number of Israelites or the number
of words contained in the Bible would
indicate in other words if you were to
collect all of the texts in cuneiform
that tell you about life in Mesopotamia
or in hieroglyphics to tell you about
life in Egypt during the period covered
by the Bible you would have a body of
writing much much longer than the Bible
but the Bible is consolidated into a
single text it's translated into every
language and it becomes it becomes the
model
if you compare the way you study the
Bible the biblical history which in most
particulars cannot be actually
documented and the way you study the
history of the other societies talked
about in this chapter you get you get a
striking difference for the story of the
Israelites you have specific stories
that now we we have tested against
archaeological datum from later parts
against corroborating texts that you
have in other languages and so forth but
you have a history and you tell that
history and what is left as the
impression upon people are these these
images or tropes like Adam and Eve the
garden the fall of man the flood the
division of the world among the sons of
Noah you know so forth and so on up to
the you know in the New Testament the
life of Jesus and the origins of the
Christian preaching but if you look at
the Egyptian story or the Mesopotamian
story you we can extract from from
written texts a sequence of rulers and
we can
say what those rulers did and we can
identify certain of them as great
conquerors or as you know total
schlemiel I mean it's we have a story
but the story doesn't carry an enormous
amount of weight and the story doesn't
contain the overtone of of a of a divine
oversight that you have in the story of
the Bible to some degree that has been
liberating to to historians one of the
finest scholars of the history of
ancient Mesopotamia who wrote a book
called I think ancient Mesopotamia or
maybe was early Mesopotamia a Leo
Oppenheim
is it about as good at the introduction
new Mesopotamian history as you can get
and the subtitle of it is sort of
ancient Mesopotamia the portrait of a
dead civilization and in his preface
he's very specific in saying I'm writing
about the civilization as a dead
civilization of which nothing remains
except you know the sort of fossilized
bits of lore that we can get from
tablets or from you know ruins of cities
or things of that sort
said the reason is that if I thought
that the story of ancient Mesopotamia
made any difference to us today I would
start with the question of what
difference does it make to us today but
as long as I consume that is dead and
has no lasting impact I can describe it
as it appears from the documentation so
he says let's take for example the Epic
of Gilgamesh here you have a text that
goes back almost certainly to the 4th
millennium BC it's a story about a king
of Uruk and who has a wild and hairy
friend who gets killed and he becomes
morose and he goes off to the underworld
looking for enlightenment on the nature
of life he says now there's a text that
exists in a handful of Chania form
tablets
literally a handful that it wasn't a
text that for which we have hundreds of
recensions of it you know basically you
know just a handful of tablets and we
still have in the existing versions we
still have holes in the text for you
have gaps where there is a tablet or
portion of a tablet has broken off and
we don't know quite what happens during
that you're going to jump cut from one
line to another line says how important
was the epic of gilgamesh to the
Mesopotamians it says on the one hand we
have this handful of tablets that tell
us the story on the other hand we have
thousands upon thousands of tablets that
offer instruction on how to interpret
the patterns found on the livers of
slaughtered sheep and in fact we have a
model you know baked clay model sheep
livers that are marked in cuneiform you
know this is the lobe that tells you
that section sizes low toes these are
teaching tools so that when you went to
sheep liver school you could pass this
around and say now you'll notice that
the anterior such as such Loeb tells you
how long the king will live and you get
used to handling it and then of course
you finally graduate so you have a yucky
soft sheep liver that never quite
matches when you trained on and then you
know it's like to do Anatomy in med
school then you deal with real people an
abbot of the Apennines
time says clearly divination by sheep
livers meant an enormous amount in this
in this dead civilization and doesn't
mean anything at all to us today
but I will give it proportional
treatment I will talk more about sheep
livers and I'll talk about Gilgamesh
because I'm going to follow the the
apparent importance of things as they
are manifested in the surviving
fragmentary documentation now a
contemporary of Oppenheim was Samuel
NOLA Cramer who wrote a book on the
Sumerians the earliest documented
civilization from Mesopotamia and I am
absolutely certain that Oppenheim had
great respect for Kramer and that Kramer
had great respect for Oppenheim and
these are standard introductory works
Oppenheim for the period of that comes
after the Sumerians because his
specialty was the Akkadian language
which was the language of the later
Mesopotamian states whereas Kramer was a
specialist on Sumerian which was the
language of the earliest Mesopotamian
state around 3,000 before and after
3,000 BC you read Kramer and chapter
after chapter address the question of
what did the Sumerians you know invent
that affect us still today what are the
legacies of Sumer he operates on the
assumption that the reason you want to
know about something that happened
thousands of years ago is because it
still matters it's still important to us
so
dividing a circle into 360 degrees you
know using a base 12 you know these are
things that Kramer will put great
emphasis on
although proportionally probably had
though did not have an emphasis that
would I would warrant that as it turns
out since the guilt the since the epic
of gilgamesh was originally a Sumerian
myth that gets translated into Akkadian
both authors deal with it and for Kramer
the important thing is that here is
where you get what people think of as
the earliest version of the story of
Noah and the flood and since no one the
flood are in the Bible and since the
Bible is important to us today therefore
the Epic of Gilgamesh Gilgamesh is
important to us today because of we can
trace our interest in the flood back to
that point
from from the point of view of
historical methodology this division
between Oppenheim and kramer is is a
significant one
you cannot say everything well but
differently it is possible on certain
historical topics to say everything that
is knowable because there are so few
data but on most topics you have to pick
and choose and you have to have some
principles for doing it there is a way
of looking at this that is sometimes
useful
this is a graph
this axis is the propensity of a
historian to resort to theory and this
axis is the quantity of data sorry of
the wrong axis this is theory and this
is data
and what the axe is what the graph says
is that if you have almost no
information you need some sort of
theoretical construct to make it hold
together and at the other end if you
have vast quantities of information you
need some sort of a theory to to define
what is important now that the scholarly
disciplines can be sorted on this graph
so that's something like oh let's say
early
well paleontology history of early
fossils you'll find over here you have
one bone per five million years and so
you you say well let us assume this in
this kind of thing and you try and
create a chart of the evolution of
organisms on basis of extremely little
data then here you'll have astronomy
where you have vast quantities of data
lots of stars and you need something to
hold it all together now in this graph
classically
this is where history is it is the area
where you have just enough data to tell
the story without using any fancy
theories historians let's say well into
the nineteenth and some of them even now
in the 20th century really swear by this
they'll they'll say you know if you
control your sources and that's the
idiom is used if you control your
sources I would say you you have read
every relevant source you simply tell
the story and you don't need to know
anything about economic theory or
anthropological theory or political
science theory or anything else you
simply tell the story and you'll tell it
with flair and you make it interesting
to read and people will will read your
book and they'll call you a great
historian the area where this survives
most today the part of area of history
is in biography where you can say I have
read every surviving scrap of paper
dealing with the life of Henry Luce and
you can write a great book as my
colleague Alan Brinkley has done or
Robert Caro's three volumes on on the
career of Lyndon Johnson and we read
everything talk to everyone you don't
you don't have to have any particular
Theory there but what's happened what
happened in the 20th century is that
gradually historians started to use
started to focus on more and more meager
quantities of data or more and more
abundant quantities of data and they
found themselves thrown into an area
where they relied upon theory so that
as they moved up the data-scale board
more data they started to get into
economic theory because the data might
be things like trade records that were
just you know volume after volume of
information about about Commerce and as
they went back in the other direction
they would deal with Oh Aires I know
very technological history where you
just have a few artifacts and you try
and hang them together according to your
theoretical construction of how they
were how they evolved
world history cannot readily be
approached in the in this classical
sense that is to say there's clearly too
much data and clearly you need something
to help you sort it out the the theories
that you may have may be borrowed from
other disciplines economics or political
science or anthropology but as in the
case of Kramer and Oppenheim they can
also be intrinsically historians
concerns such as how did the past do
something that affects us today or how
do we look at the past if we take as an
assumption that it is totally dead
has nothing to do with who we are today
these are two different theoretical
approaches ok the way the Bible tends to
work this is that the Bible tells you a
story and for many people that story is
a complete and adequate whereas the
parallel narrative stories even if
they're detailed that you might get for
best potamia or for the Phoenicians or
for the Egyptians those stories don't
have the the weight of the stories out
of the Bible because they haven't been
you know read in church for the last
several thousand years so
is it justified to devote a chapter so
much to the Middle East in the ancient
period and is there any way of escaping
it we I recall an author's meeting we
had that was one of our more fractious
meetings of which there were many and it
had to do with the word tribe the
africanist on our team said you cannot
use the word tribe for the peoples of
Africa because that was a word used by
colonialists and these are our nations
their peoples they're not you know
they're not tribes are not all related
to each other you can't call the Ashanti
a tribe or you can't call the you know
the Zulus a tribe it simply is is
imperialist
and our American has said you know the
same thing goes for pre-columbian
American indigenous Americans you know
we call them Indian tribes but that is
offensive so we should not do that so
then we I said you know Middle Eastern
history heck we have tribes all over the
place we have Arab tribes you Turkish
tribes your Persian tribes nobody's
complained about it then we said yeah
but we're doing a world history textbook
so we have to be consistent so after a
long debate we said ok we will ban the
word tribe from the book then our
ancient historian said but the word is a
Latin word and it was used for the early
divisions of the society in the city of
Rome how can we ban that because it is
the proper word so we said all right we
can use tribe for the tribes of Rome
which he never did it
to the point because the more important
issue was quickly talk about the twelve
tribes of Israel
because that is is one of these things
that arises from the the weight of the
Bible and we toss rise how can we talk
about the twelve kin groups of Israel
the twelve descent groups of Israel and
we ended up not talking I don't think he
put in twelve tribes of Israel he did he
did damn I think we took I think we told
him not to but but that was that was an
exception because the weight of biblical
usage became more important than the
than the weight of current
historiographical debate now there's
another there was another attack on the
tribe having to do with with
anthropological theories about the
origin of the state was particularly
carried by a colombian through ologist
named Morton freed who was a ferocious
opponent of of talking about tribes in
ancient China but but our debate stuck
mostly on this on this issue of the
offensiveness for people of African or
Native American background but anyway it
the twelve tribes of Israel got in there
and I don't think we'll ever be able to
root them out the
to my mind they're the one thing that
seems to be overarching that ties
together all the stories in this chapter
and even stretches more broadly is
something that is is part of the Bible
but it also is not exclusively part of
the Bible and that is the idea of
sacrifice sacrifice is perhaps the most
commonly encountered aspect of settled
post Neolithic life that you find on a
global basis everybody killed something
and had a good time today
sacrifice has has virtually vanished
Muslims still carry out sacrifice on
their idul adha
after the pilgrimage to Mecca each year
and you'll have certain other
sacrificial traditions you'll have
Chinese families will still sacrifice on
Family altars although those sacrifices
tend to be of foodstuffs rather than
live animals but
the fact that this practice has died out
does not mean that it was not at one
time one of the few commonalities of
human experience but nobody you know why
sacrifice occurs is a is remains a
puzzle there is a hypothesis that has
never been proven that says that all
sacrifice originated with sacrificing
humans in every part of the world and
that sacrificing animals provided a
substitution and that therefore one
should presume that before the advent of
civilizations you had a generality of of
human sacrifice yes you know
it's not a highly respected theory but
but it's a theory that has been has been
tossed around and it has been linked to
the fact that areas that don't have
suitable animals to sacrifice are often
the ones that continue to sacrifice
humans that is say particularly in the
in the new world
so the Aztecs for example sacrifice
humans but they don't sacrifice domestic
animals because they really didn't have
much in the way of domestic animals
the Incas on the other hand sacrifice
llamas because they have llamas and so
you can see how the argument would be
made the the function of sacrifice is
another way approaching it is there a
common function that is achieved through
sacrifice whether it's a sacrifice of
grain on an altar or the killing of an
animal or the killing of a human or the
pouring of wine or milk or some other
fluid on an altar or the burning of a
ghee you know clarified butter or some
other substance on the altar is there
some common function that you could that
you could assert is proper to all human
societies at a certain early stage and
if so doesn't that make it plausible
to give special emphasis to parts of the
world where information about sacrifice
is extremely abundant and that imagine
that would be a way of saying well let's
look particularly at all of those sheep
livers or when we get to the to the
Carthaginians let us look at the fact
that they sacrificed little children
where archaeologically you know huge
numbers of infant bones have been found
buried next to altars in Tunisia that
were altars that were used by the
Carthaginians in that area and doesn't
it warrant in that case a particular
emphasis upon the story of Abraham
because isn't this the one of these
things that we have from the Bible that
that really makes sense if you know that
to talk about why you do or do not mix
cotton and wool or linen and cotton
which will be prohibited according to
Orthodox Jewish law that might not be
well interesting but maybe there are
some things from the Bible that are both
biblical but also have a sort of a
generic relevance
this is one of the issues where the
Bible gives us two points of attachment
one of them is Abraham who did not
sacrifice his son Isaac and the other is
is Jesus whose crucifixion is construed
by Christians as a sacrifice and how
they construed it is a no it is a it is
either entirely metaphorical or it's
really pretty gross because you know to
a Christian phrase like you know are you
washed in the blood of the Lamb well
that can give you pause if you think of
having a bucket of lambs blood and you
know swabbing yourself down with lambs
blood and say okay now I'm washing the
blood of the lamb and you know this is
sort of unappetizing so people say well
that must not be literal but on the
other hand everybody agrees that the
idea of purifying the altar in the
temple in Jerusalem required the blood
of a red heifer and to wash with that
blood and we have an even more striking
example that in the Roman Empire there
was a very very popular cult
particularly in the Roman army which was
a cult of Mithra and uh
there are cult centers that have been
found
archaeologically in various parts of
Europe that were devoted to Mithra and
such a cult center is called a myth
realm the the feature of the cult center
that I want to point to is that they
often had a picture or a carving showing
Mithra slaying an ox and they had a
subterranean chamber over which there
was a grill and the a genuine ox was
slaughtered on the grill and the blood
would drip down onto the onto the
devotees of Mithra who are in the
chamber down below and they would
literally wash in the blood of the ox
not the blood of the lamb so when that
phrase washing the blood of the lamb
originated it was within a late ancient
world in which the idea of washing in
blood was was real and then there is the
question of eating the body and the
blood of Christ was that real to two
people I mean it becomes theologically
real as an official declaration later on
with the Catholic Church but how did
people see it the time they see it as a
symbolic commemorative event or did they
think it was real and of course one of
the striking things about the notion of
Holy Communion as the actual consumption
of the body of the blood of Christ is
that it is prohibited in Jewish law to
to eat blood so here you are you're
consuming the blood of God coming out of
a tradition of law that prohibits you
eating blood of
any kind this may seem bizarre but some
historians of Christianity in the in the
19th century who were trying to see the
rationale behind all this
use the term theology to describe
Christian practices God eating when did
the Christians start eating God some of
the scholars particularly William
Robertson Smith in his book on the
religion of the Semites dealing with the
ancient Semitic people said that we have
text showing that literally you would
have an animal who was felt to be the
representative of God you know in your
particular group and when when evening
came you would kill the animal and you
would eat it before sunrise the entire
animal would be consumed
now these sacrificial traditions so they
say we we see them in the Bible
mewls the new in the Old Testament
literally in the New Testament
hopefully metaphorically but they they
have a commonality across across
cultures because sacrifice is so so
ubiquitous so there is a
of the save the sacrifice of an ox and
eastern India I think I've given you the
text about that the me fan for a while
on YouTube they actually you could
actually see a home movie of a beef M
being being sacrificed and and you can
compare it say with yours sunday-school
picture of Abraham and Isaac and here a
nice altar and looking up and holding a
knife and there's a ram and the thicket
and it's all you know very very nice and
here is this YouTube video that shows
people just ripping apart this big cow
and jumping on it and killing it and
it's the most gross thing imaginable and
I think that you know one of the
problems of thinking about sacrifices
because we're where we find the carnal
aspects of it so unappealing but if you
don't get into it then you have problems
of how do you explain a whole lot of
phenomena that derive from ancient
practices of sacrifice
alright sacrifice is supposed to
accomplish certain things so that if you
want the Sun to rise in the morning you
have to perform a sacrifice if you want
to confirm the succession to the
kingship you have to have a sacrifice in
other words the sacrifice itself achieve
certain things it also for for animal
sacrifice provides everyone with with
meat so that in the time of same in the
time of the New Testament in the city in
the Mediterranean Basin almost all of
the meat that was available for people
to eat was temple sacrifice you didn't
have a private meat market where you
just slaughtered animals and sold sold
meat it's it makes it very questionable
then when Saint Paul talks about you're
not supposed to eat meat presented at
the temple whether he is saying
everybody has to be a vegetarian because
there wasn't any other meat around but
so you you're supposed to accomplish
something and you're supposed to provide
food but divination is another aspect
and this becomes another theme that
appears to be worldwide it isn't simply
that you carry out a sacrifice in order
to achieve you know something but it's
also in order to divine divine the
future divining the future is one of the
most constant human yemm's I think at
least you know in the post Neolithic
times people want to know what's going
to happen both on a personal basis and
on a larger basis and nowadays we call
it polling where we have an entire
division of this faculty the sociology
department dedicated to divining the
future through through polling and
through very careful statistical
interpretations of polls that allow you
to extrapolate here's where the market
is going to go or here is where the next
election is going to go I hope not and
here is this that the other thing so
divining you know is still with us
only it has become scientist as a
product of the same tendency that you
had a 19th century to tsiyon ties the
Bible you had the notion of of scient
izing divination and as you did that you
you superseded divination based on other
principles so that
the Bible and the Koran were used for
divining long before there was any
polling and this was done by looking at
the numerical value of letters because
in the Greek alphabet in the Arabic
alphabet in Hebrew alphabet and all of
the ancient alphabets that are relevant
to this chapter individual letters this
isn't true of hieroglyphics or of
cuneiform signs but in alphabetic
traditions from the Phoenicians onward
every letter had a numerical value and
therefore if you had a name you could
calculate the numerical value of that
name and certain numbers were considered
to have magical properties
sometimes the number in and of itself
sometimes numbers placed in a matrix
that you could add the values vertically
and horizontally and diagonally and come
up with the same number that would be a
magic number tremendous amount of of
divination by by numerology you still
get traces of it I discovered on the
internet when I was doing trying to find
out whether there was a sacred donkey in
Buddhism you know there is a messiah in
in Buddhism in the Pure Land Buddhism
that becomes the dominant form of
Buddhism in China and you know Messiah
who is known as the Maitreya Buddha
and the Maitreya Buddha comes at the end
of time as a messiah and then people are
saved when they go to the left to the
Western land which is paradise and you
have very much a messianic tradition and
stories of the coming of a Maitreya
Buddha appear again and again in Chinese
history as the the legends underpinning
political rebellions so the eight
trigram rebellion of 1813
it was organizationally built around
martial arts because you had martial
arts teachers went from village to
village training people and saying if
you really know the martial arts fully
you cannot be harmed this is the root of
so many movies and comic books that I'm
not going to go into Rita Lecter
assassin it's it's all there but the
mythology behind the eight trigrams
rebellion of 1813 which almost killed
the Emperor was the coming of the
Maitreya Buddha now if you take these
letters ma ITR e uya and you write it in
Hebrew and you add up the numerical
value what do you get now you get 666
you get the number of the Antichrist
which shows that that the Messiah of the
Buddhist is not like the Christian and
the Jewish Messiah or the Muslim Messiah
but he has in fact the Antichrist
now I found this on the Internet
I checked it out I you know wrote it in
Hebrew characters and did the addition
and he's right
it's 666 but by and large this sort of
divination by numbers has faded away and
is basically fairly silly but other
sorts of divination I've already
mentioned the divination by the livers
of of sheep with other sorts of
divination are worth talking about more
because they have to do with what is it
that that causes things to happen in the
world of human life in the sublunar
sphere that we inhabit and can you
predict it or if something happens
can you contextualize it according to a
broader construct that you can detect
through divination so I will pick up on
Thursday and talk some more about
divination I might be a few minutes late
on Thursday because I have a panel I'm
supposed to be on over on the east side
and I'm not sure I'll be back in time